Halle Berry
has gotten divorced
I don't really care about the personal
lives of celebrities I guess marriage
and divorce are public matters so it's
not that's not just your private life
marriage is a public thing but what
makes the story kind of interesting is
that this divorce has been going on for
something like eight years
Halle Berry has agreed to her child
support payments to her ex-husband they
finalize their divorce eight years after
this custody battle began
started in 2015 and here's what Halle
Berry said in 2015. it is with a heavy
heart that we have come to the decision
to divorce we move forward with love and
respect for one another and the shared
focus of what is best for our son
that is a nonsensical statement
we are we are deciding to divorce now
because we are totally focused on what
is best for our child
that's not possible
it's not possible
maybe in the most extreme rare
circumstance where you've got you know
an abusive husband or something like
that threatening the the wife and the
children I see the argument for a kind
of a separation there that's that's not
what's going on here that's not what's
going on in the vast majority of cases
of divorce what what people say in most
cases of divorce as well
well look it's it's not no it's not
about any threats to the children or to
me it's just it's that I just we need to
be happier you know that's exactly what
Halle Berry said she said I just feel
fulfilled I feel happy in my life
romantically as a mother as an artist
I'm a much better mother in this
circumstance than I would have been had
I stayed in the Romantic relationship
that didn't serve me and didn't make me
feel the way I need to feel as a woman
I'm reminded that we always have to take
care of ourselves first because I can't
be a good mother for my children if I'm
not fundamentally happy and feeling good
about myself this
woman is completely wrong
it is amazing to have a statement with
this many sentences where every single
one of them is just completely and
totally wrong
me me that's all that matters I'm a much
better mother in the circumstance where
you're not putting your children first
no that makes you a worse mother I'm not
knocking you entirely I know it's a
tough world I know people do get
divorced I know we deal with all the
problems of evil pervading this this
fall in place that that there are
but it's not better
to say it's better that's just a lie I'm
remind we need to take care of ourselves
first no when you're a when you're a
parent your responsibility is to take
care of your children first you have to
think about other people sometimes more
than yourself I know that's in our
modern culture it's very difficult to
think about and in Hollywood it's
virtually impossible to think about
I can't be a good mother for my children
if I'm not fundamentally happy yes you
can you know how you can by just doing
the stuff you're supposed to do and
shutting up about your feelings that's
that's how you can that's how we can all
do it I'm not just knocking Halle Berry
here this is true for everybody
you can be a good husband and a good
wife and a good father and a good mother
and a good employee and a good member of
your community
even if you're not totally perky all day
long you know how you do it you shut up
about your feelings and you think about
anybody for even one second other than
yourself and if we all did that just
like five percent more than we do our
nation our local communities all the way
up to our national Community would be so
much better we would solve so many of
our problems
just that easily right now text Knowles
to 98 98 98 as central banks and
countries like China India and Australia
begin transitioning to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
the digital currency the government
could track every single purchase you
make officials could even prohibit you
from purchasing certain products and
easily freeze or Seize Your Money these
are some of the reasons that concerned
Americans reach out to Birch gold they
want to have a physical asset like gold
that is independent of the US dollar you
can protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now learn if gold is right for you
text Knowles kwles to 98 98.98 they will
send you a free info kit on gold with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend upon text
Knowles Canada wlas 298-98 98 new homes
are shrinking in size I teased this
story on Friday
this is my little tease it's not the
sexiest story it's not the most
scintillating sensationalist tabloid
story but it tells you something really
deep about our country
yeah this is from Wall Street Journal
goodbye bathtub in living room America's
homes are shrinking faced with high
mortgage rates constrained Americans are
embracing smaller homes
for many Americans homeownership may be
attainable only if they give up the
dining room home prices are in your
record highs frustrating millions of
potential buyers to say nothing of the
fact that interest rates are not through
the roof
uh since 2018 the average unit size for
new housing starts has decreased 10
percent nationally to 2420 square feet
now I I read that number and I thought
man that's a mansion 2400 Square the
house I grew up in I grew up in an
apartment for a lot of my upbringing but
then we I grew up in a house that was I
think 800 square feet I thought 2400 is
pretty good except you gotta you gotta
remember I grew up in New York
if you grew up in the middle of the
country where real estate is cheaper
okay 2400 that's not as big as it used
to be and then in other places you look
at Seattle
newly built homes
are 18 smaller than they were five years
ago Charlotte North Carolina and San
Antonio 14 smaller than they were four
years ago this stuff is shrinking really
really fast
why
in part it's shrinkflation it's the
reason that when you go to the grocery
store you get less coffee in the tin of
coffee than you did
a few years ago
you get fewer Donuts in the bag of
donuts it's because when inflation is
rampant as it has been under Joe Biden
uh
companies know that they can't just Jack
the price up 50 percent or you'll be so
shocked by that so they'll Jack the
price up 20 but then they'll shrink the
package so the cost per unit goes up a
lot that's part of the reason but but
it's also because
our families are shrinking
people have many fewer children now than
they did 50 years ago
it's also because our whole population
is shrinking we have a dying population
in the United States as we have for 50
years
and that trend has accelerated at
various times in those 50 years
our whole our whole civilization is
shrinking it's smaller than it used to
be
our view of art you walk into a
cathedral in Europe or even in America
you walk into St Pat's cathedral in New
York this is big this is Grand this is
huge this is beautiful you look at
modern architecture it's small
you look at more traditional
architecture it's ornamented there's a
lot to it there are a lot of details to
take in modern architecture you look at
the new homes that people are building
you know there's hideous like black and
white kind sometimes Cube
now occasionally more angular
monstrosities they look like prisons
they look like the kind of place you get
sent if you send memes out on Twitter
supporting Donald Trump you know they
they don't they're just small and ugly
you see this in the the novel The
Fountainhead by Ein Rand her slightly
lesser red novel to Atlas Shrugged and
slightly smaller but equally bad The
Fountainhead is a novel about einran's
philosophy of objectivism which is an
atheist materialist ideology but it's
it's also about architecture and what's
so funny about the book is Ein Rand is
wrong about 97 of things she she
actually gets to some interesting truths
about human nature about three percent
of the time but it's just totally
covered up in a bunch of muck and false
anthropology and and theology
but she the most striking thing about
the novel which is about architecture is
that she's wrong about architecture
the protagonist of the novel makes a a
church he's supposed to make a cathedral
basically and it's this small tiny ugly
crappy modern place
the the the vision that the protagonist
of the story pursues so doggedly without
getting any advice from anybody
including the people who are paying for
his plans his artistic vision is ugly
it's just modernist
unhuman small
stuff it's ugly and so it's no surprise
that everything's shrinking you know we
joke about how the lips want to make us
all eat bugs and live in pods this is
how they do it the way they make you
live in a pod is not by putting a gun to
your head
and saying get in the Pod now surf you
know the way they make you live in a pod
is they shrink your expectations they
shrink your vision of the world
of course they they make it they shrink
your hopes and your your dreams and your
imagination such that you are content
living in a way that is not fitting of a
dignified human being boy what a great
clip that was huh now make sure you ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time